vraiment bien je deviens tu veux pas
juste qui fait et pas du tout juste
celle là il ya le soleil la piscine la
boisson y'avait toi avant que tu sois
chiant et dans deux heures avant 12
heures j'en aurai marre il faut danser
le même soleil même piscine comme
chaleurs m boissons peut-être même que
je serai plus au pouvoir vous dire
pourquoi cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode du coup de fil
alors on va parler du désir dans la vie
si vous avez déjà réfléchi vous êtes
rendu compte que la satisfaction
elle vient pas d'elle même et à
satisfaction parce que ça compte quelque
chose et à satisfaction parce que ça
comble un désir d'ailleurs c'est la
satisfaction de ce désir là et quand ce
désir est satisfait
miles est ce parce qu'on lui a donné
tout ce qu'ils voulaient a renoncé pas
tout désir qui cesse sinon ce serait
trop facile c'est juste que tu as tu
mettras désiré autre chose mais ton
désir là qui étaient à la source de
satisfaction ben vu qu'ils cessent la
jouissance ton kif qui venait de cette
satisfaction là et bref c'est souci mon
café
en fait une fois qu'on a atteint l'objet
de désir on revient au stade où on était
avant de vouloir satisfaire ce désir
c'est en tout cas la thèse que défend
schopenhauer vous chopez qui nos erreurs
arthur schopenhauer c'est un philosophe
allemand du 19e siècle qu'un vachement
inspiré des mecs comme nietzsche ou war
freud au point aux fraudes il a avoué
avoir arrêté de lire schopenhauer parce
qu'il avait peur que ça m'influence trop
dans sa pensée
david guetta dû faire pareil que mozart
son oeuvre principale s'appelle le monde
comme volonté et comme représentation et
vous trouverez à peu près toute sa
pensée dedans pour l'anecdote ce que
j'aime bien les anecdotes il a légué une
grosse partie de sa fortune à son chien
et sa gouvernance pour qu'elle s'occupe
de son chien après faut savoir que la
pensée de schopenhauer et quand même
grave pessimiste et rien dans cette
vidéo vous allez en avoir un aperçu
alors déjà pour lui le bonheur c'est
négatif alors c'est pas négatif dans le
sens où ça va nous faire mal ou alors
dans le sens où il faut pas aller le
chercher
c'est en fait le concept même de bonne
heure c'est la négation d'un truc il
faut enlever quelque chose pour y
accéder c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu à
l'heure avec la satisfaction et le
contentement et ben en fait la
satisfaction et le contentement
c'est l'arrêt d'une douleur ou d'une
privation qui vient d'un désir oui parce
que si tu désires beaucoup un truc et
que tu ne l'as pas eh ben tu souffres
c'est pour ça qu'il dit d'ailleurs la
phrase la vie aussi tel un pendule de
droite à gauche de la souffrance à
l'ennui et il va même plus loin parce
qu'il sépare clairement le moyen qu'on a
de ressentir la douleur ou la souffrance
par exemple par rapport aux moyens qu'on
a de ressentir de la satisfaction en
fait pour lui la différence entre les
deux c'est la médiathéque bien inquiet
immédiat qui va venir à toi sans
intermédiaire directement
c'est ce qui concerne pas la souffrance
la douleur la privation le besoin par
exemple si tu as soif
ça va venir à toi directement sans
intermédiaire immédiatement par an quand
tu bois tu désaltère tu as une certaine
satisfaction parce que tu as eu un désir
avant la soif donc c'est un direct en
fait d'une manière générale les
avantages ou les biens que tu as
possession
bah tu en as pas vraiment conscience ou
tuent les apprécie pas vraiment en tout
cas pas à leur juste valeur
tant que tu les as tu considères presque
que c'est normal de les avoir avoir une
meuf qui t'aime ouais normal
mes parents veille sur moi normal avoir
des amis pour s'éclater avec avoir un
téléphone portable avoir encore qui
fonctionne avoir un énorme pénis ouais
tout ça c'est normal
alors qu'en fait non je pourrais très
bien ne pas les avoir mais ça tu t'en
rends compte que si tu fais l'effort d'y
penser c'est un direct en fait je vous
ai dit que c'était un peu pessimiste
tout va comme vous voulez monsieur
chopin à moi j'ai une vie de merde
le poste l'image vous deviez mais il
n'est pas si pessimiste que ça parce
qu'ils essaient de nous apporter des
solutions dès lundi que l'intervalle
entre le désir et la satisfaction ils
doivent être ni trop long ni trop court
bon ok on va pas les hyper loin avec ça
mais pour lui il ya d'autres solutions
qui permettent de s'échapper de cette
pendule qui va de la souffrance à
l'ennui alors il y en a une comme
développera ensemble plus tard parce que
c'est très proche du bouddhisme de la
maîtrise des divers etc et l'autre c'est
l'art en gros on va s'élever de ce
ping-pong incessants et on va arriver à
une contemplation désintéressé mais
selon lui ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
est accessible à tout le monde
en vrai j'aurais pu m'arrêter là mais
vous auriez pas eu toute la saveur qu'il
ya derrière
et pour ça j'ai besoin de vous
introduire un autre concept de
schopenhauer qui s'appelle la volonté
vous souvenez quand j'ai parlé de son
livre son hub principal s'appelle le
monde comme volonté et comme
représentation et vous trouverez toute
sa pensée dedans et d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote avant que l'anecdote on va
juste revenir sur le titre comme volonté
et comme représentation
c'est une dualité qui est très inspirée
de quand donc on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais moi je le sais m'arrêter
sur le mot volonté ici en fait de la
volonté avec un v majuscule chez
schopenhauer ça n'a rien à voir avec le
mot volonté comme on a l'habitude de
l'entendre ses plus proches genre de la
force dans star wars par exemple c'est
une force qui est naturel objective qui
ne veut que se perpétue et qui se
manifeste dans tout ça va du minéral à
l'animal ces gens l'inertie dans la
matière la sexualité chez les vivants
c'est un truc qui est très proche de ce
qu'on a pu voir chez spinoza par exemple
mais pas que souvenez vous ce que j'ai
dit un peu plus tôt plus qu'à vachement
inspiré des mecs comme nietzsche et
c'est pour ça que nietzsche a appelé son
concept la volonté de puissance toute
équipe
bref cette volonté du coup elle
s'exprime au travers de plein de choses
et aussi au travers de nous c'est ce
qu'on appelle le vouloir vivre et dès
qu'un élément on se met au travers de
son chemin
on souffre quand l'effort de la volonté
est arrêté par quelques obstacles entre
elle et son but du moment voilà la
souffrance
donc en fait la souffrance c'est quelque
chose qui est naturel et nécessaire
ça peut pas être autrement tout vouloir
a pour principe un besoin un manque donc
une douleur c'est par nature
nécessairement qu'ils doivent devenir la
proie de la douleur mais quand on
contemple dollars c'est quelque chose
qui est désintéressé vu que s'est
désintéressé c'est un exercice qui se
fait hors de la volonté
donc on se libère du vouloir vivre et
donc c'est pour ça que c'est une
solution pour schopenhauer ou tu la sens
ma grosse intelligence si tu as encore
de la satisfaction face à cette vidéo et
que t'as pas encore le désir de mater
une autre vidéo
je t'invite à ta bonne et c'est pas déjà
fait pour pas rater les prochaines et
surtout placer le coup de fil à un ami
c'est plus important nous envoie du love
et de la pisse et soyez heureux
ian là j'espère que cet épisode vous
aura plu donc je paie noir c'est
quelqu'un qui a été vachement inspiré
aussi par le bouddhisme
quand il a lu l'histoire du coude à etc
les quelques révélations machin dont on
reparlera tout ça je pense quand on
parlera du bouddhisme parce que c'est un
truc dont je vais parler forcément un
autre point que j'ai vaguement évoqué
c'est celui de cette dualité entre le
monde comme volonté et comme
représentation josée lyne dualité entre
ge et quand en tête quand j'ai fait un
épisode pour l'instant qu'un épisode sur
la raison pratique on va faire un autre
truc soit la raison pure donc j'en
parlerai à ce moment là n'hésitez pas à
me suivre sur facebook twitter snapshots
et trois réseaux que j'utilise vraiment
différemment
donc voilà 6,6 l'univers vous plaît et
ce n'est pas un me suivront là dessus
merci encore une fois à tous les types
heures vous êtes au max vous êtes gros
love love love love sur vous merci et on
se revoit la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo à la même heure soyez là
soyez présents